[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa wait a minute
are you that asian guy from Westeros
Leatherface right now I can't believe
that you thought this yeah I'm just so
used to seeing you like full bodies yeah
buildin a mess we can see the body
language anyway I'm glad you're still
working I think really good really great
into character oh all right doing me
well hello there reject nation my name's
Greg Albert my name is Joan I'm free
we're gonna talk about leather face to
dice right but before we do that we
would like to give a quick thank you to
our friends over at CTV cinemas if you
guys haven't seen last week we posted a
vlog Kyle and I we went to go check out
C GB cinemas haunted theatre experience
in Buena Park yeah I got to experience
this for the first time this past week
yeah we're gonna and we're gonna be
there again next week to watch jigsaw
over there they have a bunch of
Halloween decorations a lot of spooky
things going on they even updated it
from last week they got even more cool
stuff going on and they had the awesome
4dx experience which we got to
experience with leonardo nam from
Westworld as you guys saw her a little
intro video here
the 40x is an awesome experience please
go ahead and check out our vlog because
it was seriously worth it put a lot of
work in that vlog too so be worth it
just for me appreciate it so yea well
jhonny will probably be there on
saturday to go watch jigsaw over there
and yeah it's an awesome theater and
even though my feelings on the movie
you'll see how they are I will say the
theater experience was still good oh
yeah the theaters I had a great time I
like about the theatre when you walk
inside when the trailers were playing
the lights go up in the hallway
yeah well the amenities man unless it's
like based on a German train station or
something more different for different
popcorns to choose from and you also
have only seven minutes of trailers it's
pretty deluxe alright well we spent a
long time giving them a shout out
because there's a lot of great things
about it anyway you want to get the
positives out of the way this movie
Leatherface the 8 film in the Texas
Chain Saw series and this movie I was
actually really interested in watching I
watched the original Texas Chainsaw
Massacre for the first time all the way
through watching this movie I didn't see
that complaint that some people probably
felt about like the Halloween remakes
and in terms of I don't think this
character could be ruined by having you
know an origin tale about him and seeing
the psychology of how this Leatherface
guy became Leatherface because there's a
whole family of personalities in the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre and plus when
you see Leatherface because he's kind of
a emotional wreck of a guy he's not just
some quiet wandering monster he makes a
lot of noises there's even one moment
where he looks really disgruntled and
bothered by the actions he's committed
he's almost like a giant child in a way
that stunted and he feels very often
there's tons of that across the Sawyer
family which kind of makes the idea of
exploring who they are more interesting
yeah then perhaps Michael Myers where
the point is that he's just the shape
and I know we had Texas Chainsaw
Massacre at the beginning which was a
prequel to the Jessica Biel one and this
was supposed to be like ideally the
prequel to the original Texas Chainsaw
Massacre so I thought this all sounded
really cool we saw the trailer
I love the trailer I thought it was I
thought look fantastic the imagery
looked awesome when watching this movie
I'll give you the positives the imagery
it's shot really well I feel like a lot
of credit of this film go slow
right here a photographer oh yeah and
the rhythm of the editing in time with
that you know not for the memo not the
pace of the movie yeah technical rhythm
of the editor yes punchy yes and if
you're a gore fan who's plenty of gore
to be had in here there's some good
cringe-worthy moments in there and
overall there's you know it's a Texas
Chainsaw world so there's a lot of
psychotic characters one thing you got
to give this franchise a good benefit is
and including this film is that the
performance is a lot of the psychotic
characters when you step back from what
you feel about the writing and the
storytelling and you just look at the
performances you're like these are
actually pretty good actors oh yeah the
actors bring a lot you believe in action
value yeah make them likeable but it but
your good thing about the tone in the
aura and and those that's based on
things coming together it's the
production value and the cinematography
and the actors themselves make this
movie feel the way it's supposed to feel
and yeah that's a good thing about it
however all that being said I personally
kind of hated the film an awful lot at
the end of this video we'll give us what
we'll get we'll give a little like two
minutes spoiler talk that way you guys
can really understand why I especially
had an issue with this film but that
will say that for the I was watching
this movie and there's like three
different intros and I really felt like
this movie could start off on just a
third intro and it would have been way
more intriguing I think the movie has
plenty of opportunities where it could
take time to slow down and just give us
a full-on scene it could have used more
dynamic pace yeah the pacing is just so
all over the place and the space oh yes
- the focus of who were focusing on it
keeps shifting around - who's the
primary focus I couldn't ever really get
hooked it not that I look for like the
redeeming characters in a Texas Chain
Saw movie but there really is not many
redeeming characters in here it's a
weird ensemble piece where everything
feels kind of rush yeah yeah you never
get to know anybody all that well so
you're left with sort of like I'm
curious about these different characters
and that's kind of all you get the main
issue I have with this film
halfway through I looked at John and I
was like I'm so glad this movie is not
focusing on Leatherface the entirety the
main story is really about these group
of escaped mental it's like Bonnie and
Clyde asylum
patients who break out with a nurse and
they break out with another dude who's
like cool Asylum patient guy have the
two completely insane knee list again
just like yes ranch or Born Killers kind
of guys and then you've got this big
sort of hulking quiet guy and then you
have the charming ya know seemingly
well-adjusted mental patient and then
the nurse who just wants to happen and
there's a little bit of focus on the
Sawyer family you know how you see the
trailer and you're like oh we're gonna
get the origin tale of Leatherface and
his mother who we didn't get as seen the
original Texas Chainsaw Lily Taylor
honestly just comes in periodically
throughout this film and Stephen Dorff
and Stephen one too and Stephen Dorff is
just angry sheriff who hates psychotic
kids yeah he's it's like it's like think
of the Devil's Rejects but if you didn't
see the part where the sheriff gets that
way he's just angry and yeah it's kind
of boring to me in the first half and
while there's a lot of gore that comes
in like every 10 to 20 minutes really
gory there's some gory stuff I found
myself becoming rather immune to it
because it starts off like so early on
within the film of so much gore gore
starts to proceed I'm like I'm not even
like cringing anymore it is cringed did
there was one dealing with like
necrophilia even in the theater there I
was just like I just hate this movie and
I have no soul it's just one note it's
so it's a one note film it is the same
tone it starts off loud and messy and
chaotic and then it just stays there for
like the entire team with no level of
likability whatsoever and it's super
rush it's ugly and bleak and Gnostic and
there's a water might sound like it
that's what it's supposed to be it
doesn't work for this film well cuz the
problem is this movie tries to split the
difference between that 70s vibe of like
oh you're just in a sort of immediate
situation that's unfolding but let's
also cram it into super fast pace yeah
and it comes out really weird because of
that and yeah like I like an ugly movie
sometimes which is part of what keeps me
from hating this at the end of it all I
did have to sit there and think what is
the point what yeah what is this movie
exactly it's supposed to be about when
you see the trailer and then
you see the movie - you're like this had
the perfect opportunity to be a
psychological study of his relationship
with his mom growing up and the distance
he had and this conflict he has of
becoming this like cannibalistic serial
killer it doesn't do any that
exploration instead you get a plot about
escape asylum patients on the run with
an evil share of hunting them down so
there's no one good in this movie and
the biggest upset to me about this film
was and I've seen on Rotten Tomatoes
capsules were they were they're kind of
hinting at it about the mystery and and
the misleads that go on in his films
yeah the whodunit
what pissed me off so much cuz this
whole like plot twist and misdirection
that you can feel the writers being like
oh we're clever but really you're just
like no you sacrificed something that
could have been really cool for this
misdirection this mislead one if you're
a Texas Chainsaw fan it my plain and
simple might just be too hard to swallow
anymore less sense to in terms of who
Leatherface is yeah see the thing about
this movies I feel like they had a
couple very questionable ideas and some
really cool ideas cuz I can't fault the
movie for trying to do something
different than this animal like the
beginning is kind of just a repeat with
a ten-minute engine that kind of
explains where Leatherface came from so
this has a lot of different ideas and
the thing is I wish this movie had more
breathing room I feel weird saying I
wish it was longer but it's like if you
fleshed any of this out because the
juxtapositions are kind of interesting
because you have the awful family the
awful law-enforcement and these kids in
the middle yeah well you could have
trimmed some stuff down and expanded
some other stuff out some have it have
some breathing room before it seems that
it had a sort of tension not stuff worst
part is Leatherface origins and then
shares prom with a Sawyer family and
then a whole insane asylum story and
then on the road story it just keeps
going all over the place the film's
overall predictable it's kind of boring
it's pretty OneNote yeah visually it
looks cool but that was so thin when you
got such a poorly written story it's
just really poorly written and when he
got such good actors in there you're
like I wish this was a better movie
weirdly how I was telling John on the
way back what Rob Zombie did for
Halloween which wasn't acceptable for
the masses
have been perfectly applicable for a
Leatherface origin I think that would
have worked better especially and I feel
like what they did for Leatherface would
it work better for Halloween for the
masses as a horror movie the way this
shakes out it's more gross than it is
ever scary and every sensible like it
might disgust you but it's not actually
gonna you know creep you out cuz the
original one it doesn't have to be that
but the original one is very unsettled
yeah an eerie and this one doesn't
really manage those things so much yeah
it's just nasty and thinks it's cooler
than what it really is then film just
honestly got on my nerves there's one of
those rare movies I'm like I'm just
annoyed if I were to give it a rant give
it like a 1 out of 5 stars I'll give it
like a 2 maybe a 2 and a half of them
feeling generous good for you Joe it's
like there's just big due to my
sensibilities there's more stuff that I
found you know kind of satisfactory
there are some ideas I liked I liked
that it didn't get super lazy and just
rehash but the weird thing is it's
another one of those movies you look at
what the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
inspired and then you watch this movie
take cues from those movies so you're
like oh yeah Devil's Rejects and like
this movie in that movie you're like
it's kind of weird to watch a classic
franchise now start aping other movies
the original one inspired all right so
this is the spoiler part this is the
spoiler talk that we're gonna have leave
if you don't want to know when you're
watching this movie when the and same
the patience with me insane asylum
escape in there you got the body and
clod wannabes and then you have Jackson
the nurse and then you have the guy
named bud who the whole time the movie
is giving you the impression that this
is leather face when they're related I
missed that part but but yeah bud and
Jackson are like cousins the whole time
the movies giving you the impression
that this is Leatherface and it only
makes sense yeah the way the guy is
because if you watch the original Texas
Chainsaw the loaded faces he's fat
alright guys this guy's overweight and
then he's really quiet and kind of
socially awkward and you could see he's
sensitive but gets his temper that comes
out of him yeah he's like a really big
chunk which is how they're portraying
bud in the movie eventually curb stomps
Clyde as they can and then when that
happens I was thinking to myself like
okay I'm starting to get where this
films going we've been setting up all
these other character
and now through this crazy journey
Leatherface is being born and the
violent angry sensitive side of him is
coming out what happens when he has to
fend for himself in a terrible situation
with these people about 15 20 minutes
later bug gets shot in the head and is
killed and you're like huh
maybe maybe that's what causes him to
become just completely deranged is that
maybe this is one of those things where
they survive and he shot him like in the
back or something and it just grazed his
brain and Jackson is super close to bud
and he's blaming the nurse for why the
cop shot bud he finally has a freakout
moment to justify why he might have been
in the hospital but it also seemed like
a reasonable emotional freakout for even
a regular dude a Jackson he gets shot
over here takes up half of his face
oh he's gonna die then my second thought
was oh [ __ ] oh here it comes and then
you find out okay Jackson is really the
leather is it this whole mislead this
misdirection a charming sexy eloquent
Jackson they wanted you to believe that
bud was Leatherface the entire time but
no really this is an origin tale of
Jackson who still doesn't get as much
focus as the Bonnie and Clyde characters
I mean he gets the most focus beyond
them why if sets me is because it just
doesn't make any sense in terms of
origin tale of who leather faces because
why is Bud I like you could just feel
them going oh this is clever they think
they're gonna be watching leather face
this is bud but it's not when you're
watching the moon like but who but is
makes a million times more sense to be
leather face than whoever the [ __ ]
Charming Jackson so many sweaty years
before so I guess you can pass it off
like oh I guess he's gonna put on some
weight and stop talkin when he switches
though I'm like I think the actor does
his best to sell it so he does a good
job but in terms of storytelling I'm
like this is stupid that is so stupid
you know like this would have been a way
more interesting movie if he just
committed to what I thought they were
doing when bud curve stops the guy
because then I'm like okay
seeing the birth of Leatherface coming
here to quiet sensitive fat dude who I
really care about because they're super
sympathetic towards him and that's
effective and then when you kill him and
then you do this plot to us they
sacrifice what could have been super
effective because they thought they were
being clever and after that I was like
[ __ ] this movie I didn't have as strong
of a reaction as you did to that I mean
I thought that the the tone and the
actors sold it decently to where by the
end I was like yeah alright I like
watching this happen but it's true like
the first movie has that quality where
you're watching a bunch of other people
before you meet Leatherface for a while
and yeah that moment where Budd finally
steps up and levels that guy I thought
the movie was gonna do that like fade
him in yeah and be like okay now we're
gonna shift and watch the monster grow
just to undo that in a way that just
leaves you going wait what is weird and
jarring and I just yeah I don't I'm not
a fan of it it didn't make me like throw
up my hands and go [ __ ] this movie but I
was like ah yeah I just really thought
there was a much better movie had this
yeah okay if you had bud what they were
setting up to just do that because then
we would have seen a psychological
progression of a guy transforming into
the monster we know his leather face I
thought there might almost be a thing
where like Jackson and Betty can get
away and Leatherface is gonna go do his
thing or something like that difference
end to the story and yeah it just takes
this alternate route that's a bit tough
to swallow
I was already not like in the movie
before that but then after that I was
like I hate this movie I feel like the
best place this is gonna play is like if
you are a fan of tone and style and gore
and stuff and you're not as concerned
with having you know a nuanced plot of
any kind for your eighth film put this
on TV you might have a good time alright
guys well that's our review of
Leatherface they just see it did you
love it what would you rank it in the
Texas Chainsaw awesome franchise you can
subscribe to the reel rejects please
click that notification bell to get
notified every time one of our videos is
up dat John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram and also please go to see GV
cinemas haunted theater experience at
Buena Park I'm telling you guys it
really is worth it it's an awesome
theater and I love all the cool scares
it's cool going last time because a lot
of people were getting scared and like
yeah as we were filming [ __ ] people were
just walking by here's people screaming
at other scare
going on yeah yeah it was fun there's a
really great time